[Music]
good afternoon everyone thanks for
coming to our session
my name is Wu Mei Shanker I'm a
principal engineer at Google based in
our New York office I'm the technical
lead for access transparency and my name
is Joseph Valente I'm a product manager
also based in our New York office and
I'm the PM for access transparency so it
takes a tremendous amount of trust to
put your data on the public cloud and
it's very difficult to gain that trust
when you don't have full visibility over
what's happening to your data and so
that's why today we're really excited to
talk about access transparency it's a
new product only available on GCP and it
gives you full visibility over what
happens to your data on the cloud so we
know that companies in every industry
are increasingly using software and data
to change the way that they do business
this isn't just true for companies in
the technology and finance and other
industries that have used software for a
very long time it's also true for
businesses in manufacturing and
logistics and even in mining where we're
seeing lots of companies that previously
never even hired a software engineer now
running multiple teams at scale
deploying software to production daily
and the public cloud is very important
in these situations because it gives you
the flexibility it gives you the ability
to manage your costs and it also gives
you the availability of technology that
you need in order to facilitate that
shift
now at Google we know a lot about
building great software teams over the
last few years we've built seven
separate businesses each with over a
billion users on them and in order to do
this we needed to build a phenomenal
internal cloud the internal cloud we
built out is the same one that we make
available to you through Google cloud
platform and it combines incredible
enterprise-grade reliability with
superfast compute and storage as well as
security and compliance and in order to
do this we had to completely reinvent
the way that the data center works from
the ground up and we've done such an
incredible job of it that now people
instead of going and checking whether
their internet works just go to
google.com because they assume that
Google will be up and we're really
really happy to be able to offer this to
you there's a saying as well that says
that anyone who's serious about making
software makes their own hardware as
well and at Google were obviously very
serious about making software which is
why we make our own hardware and that's
what you can see on the screen right now
this is one of our custom tensor
processing unit chips it's completely
designed in-house by Google and it's
available to you to use on Google cloud
platform why did we build this chip
because we wanted to take machine
learning to the next level we wanted to
completely optimize the experience of
running machine learning computations in
a data center and this chip is 15 to 30
times faster than a conventional
processor for machine learning
applications think about being seven
years into the future in terms of what
you're able to do with your computer
that's what we can do with this chip now
how do we use this internally at Google
we use machine learning at Google to
actually invest in how we cool our own
data centers data center cooling is a
really really complicated thing you need
to take into account the weather outside
the heat of the data center you need to
take into account the pumps and the
pipes and the ducts and it's a really
complicated equation for a human to
solve so we set up a machine learning
classifier and we asked to optimize all
the variables in the equation and we
were able to cut the costs of cooling
our data centers
by 40% it was a job that was so big that
we thought there was an error in the cut
in the calculation but we're excited
that you guys will also be able to do
this in your own businesses using things
like the TPU
only on Google cloud but being on the
cloud means having people to run the
cloud people who are going to help you
achieve that level of reliability
achieve that level of usability and
achieve that level of security and very
specifically in the case of Google cloud
platform it's these people not not these
specific three people because we have
slightly more than that running people
working on Google cloud today but Google
cloud software engineers is what I meant
to say and these people the people who
are responsible for making sure that
your service is always reliable it's
always up and running when you need it
and part of working with a new group of
software engineers is developing a new
relationship of trust so in your on-prem
environment you probably had vendors you
had employees you had people who are
working to make sure that your systems
are reliable and you developed a
relationship of trust with these people
over a long period of time moving to the
public cloud is no different it just
involves you entering into a new
relationship of trust with a new group
of people and that's what we hope to
give you a bit more information about in
today's talk so so far I've spoken about
cloud migration I've talked about how
important it is for changing the way
people do business the flexibility the
reliability the cost management and I've
spoken about big data and machine
learning how exciting that is and how
many opportunities that's going to open
up for all of us in every business in
every industry and I've also started to
talk a little bit about security
compliance and trust now the challenge
for you today is that these three big
themes can't be tackled independently
every business is trying to do all these
things at the same time and that's very
very difficult in a changing environment
and it really really helps to have a
cloud provider that you can trust that
they're investing in security and
compliance to bring you up to speed at
the rate you need and that's going to be
the focus of today's presentation so
before we can enjoy all these incredible
benefits of being on the cloud
we need to get a few things right
security
am i secure in the cloud a recent survey
by high trust of cloud buys globally
found that the top two fears of people
purchasing cloud were malicious or
accidental exposure of workload data and
uncontrolled or unmonitored access by
admins I want you to think about those
two things because we're going to come
back and touch on them later in this
presentation
compliance can I meet my compliance
obligations now this is not just about
compliance with external policies that
you may have to comply with or external
certifications it's also about
compliance with your own internal
policies and being able to have
visibility and certainty that you can
certify that those things have been
abided by and finally trust can I trust
my cloud provider this is related to
security and compliance but it's
slightly different this is more of an
emotional thing is the person that I'm
in business with along with me for the
journey to make me successful so these
are the three needs that we need in
order to move on to the cloud but the
way that we see it at Google is that in
order to meet these three needs we need
three foundational pillars in place
technology operations and accountability
and to talk to you more about these
three the these three pillars I'm going
to invite a mesh thanks Joe first thing
we're going to talk about is technology
if you don't have a secure technology
stack from the ground up nothing else
really matters no amount of operations
no amount of accountability is going to
save you if your data is not
fundamentally safe we look at this
problem as a series of layers right you
have your hardware at the bottom you
have it all the way up through your
application layer at the top the
software that's actually running on the
platform and we've actually invested in
every one of these layers to make it
secure to harden it and to address all
those three aspects that Joe talked
about
so let's let's start at the bottom we're
gonna dive into each one in turn it used
to be the case and you know but
by-and-large still is true that if you
order a piece of hardware you get it as
the manufacturer intended it
unfortunately it's not always true and
there have been real attacks in the wild
where the supply chain has been
compromised so your company you order a
piece of hardware or maybe a network
card is shown in this picture and it
shows up with malware already installed
on the card
maybe the firmware has already been
compromised because someone inserted
themselves in the supply chain this is a
real thing that happens and it's
something that we actually very actively
worry about at Google we've taken steps
to directly address this problem we've
actually developed a custom chip which
we call Titan which gives us a hardware
route of trust for both machines and
peripherals so on this network card
which is the kind of thing you might
find in any of our machines in our
production network there's actually this
little titan chip on that card today and
what that does is allows us to verify
the integrity of all the firmware and
other components that are on the card so
when it comes online we know it hasn't
been tampered with
relative to where it started so as you
might imagine we have a lot of machines
at Google and you can see them
represented by these little boxes
unfortunately I'm not allowed to say
exactly how many machines we have I'm
allowed to give you a range so it's
somewhere between a hundred and ten
billion that I can tell you but and each
one of those machines can be in a
different state right so some might have
just been booted up some might be
running some software some might have
been online for a while and are at an
older version of software how do you
kind of manage these things and make
sure that things are in a good state
over time again here if we look at what
it takes to startup a machine you turn
it on you load the BIOS that loads the
bootloader and so forth we've actually
taken steps at each stage of this
process to harden each thing so we use
Titan 2 at power on
to make sure that the next thing is
loaded correctly we do our own custom by
us where we've actually hardened it and
made sure there's no extraneous software
we've done the same thing for the
bootloader we've done the same thing for
the Linux kernel so we actually pair
away all the parts of the kernel we
don't actually really need to run things
in our data centers and we actively
contribute security improvements to the
kernel itself and finally the OS image
the software that runs as the base image
on the platform is something that's very
carefully managed and curated at the
same time we keep a cryptographic
trusted boot chain as each stage is
loaded so we start from Titan at the
bottom we get to buy us next and as the
BIOS loads the bootloader and the
bootloader starts to kernel each one
signs the next thing and what's so
important about this is when the process
is complete we know that each step was
genuine no one could have changed or
inserted something along the way a
really fundamental concept in the way
that we think about security is that of
identity to run a cloud to run a data
center you need services you need
machines and you need people and we
assign each one of these things an
identity in our system so we just saw
all the steps that a machine has to go
through and rotor to boot well what we
do is we only assign a machine and
identity at the end of that process and
because virtually everything works by
one thing talking to another thing over
some communications channel if you don't
have that identity you don't get to talk
to anything else
so only authentic machines even get to
talk to anything similarly we apply a
same philosophy to services and to
people for people to get an identity
they have to pass both a two-factor
authentication check which involves a
secure Hardware second factor and they
have to be coming from a trusted managed
device if they don't pass those things
they don't get an identity which means
they can't talk to machines and they
can't talk to services which effectively
means they can't do anything interesting
which is as it should be
we actually as it turns out
do the same thing for services as well
and we're gonna come back to that in a
couple minutes you'll see how we have
the same notion of identity for a
service and how we make that notion
strong so we talked about how
communication is constant each of these
kinds of things are talking to the other
during the normal operation of a data
center and each link is strongly
authenticated so when we say identity we
actually mean giving something a
cryptographic certificate that contains
its identity and so whenever you have a
link where one thing's talking to
another one party always has a strong
idea of who the other party is and you
can use that to make decisions about
whether it's what it expected what it's
allowed to do and so forth all right so
we've got our data center up and running
we've given identities the things
they're communicating things are
starting to work we're getting some data
in the door how do we manage that data
well one of the most basic and important
things we can do is make sure that data
stays encrypted both in transit and at
rest all the data coming from use
customers to Google is protected with
TLS so it's encrypted in transit there
and then within the data center in
between data centers we actually use a
combination of hardware and software
encryption to make sure it stays
encrypted across network links when
we're about to store the data in other
words to repose the data we actually
take it and we encrypt it in chunks with
different encryption keys and this kind
of ties back to what we looked at a
moment ago then the question becomes who
gets to decrypt the data who gets to
have the key and so our highly secured
key management system will only hand
keys for let's say cloud BigTable data
to the service that manages cloud
BigTable and it knows it's that service
because it has a very specific identity
the cloud BigTable services identity is
distinct from that of all the other
software and that's how we make sure
that data only flows in the appropriate
direction so I said a minute ago that we
have this notion of identity for
services as well
and this is really critical to the way
that our whole system functions so let's
come back to our example of cloud
BigTable data you create a cloud
BigTable incidence we store that
somewhere access to that data in storage
is tightly guarded by an access control
list and we will list all the machines
people services anything that's allowed
to access it must appear there or the
access is not allowed so let's say we
have the system that actually serves
cloud BigTable data back to you as the
user that needs to appear here but what
does it mean how do we know what things
ought to be in that list what
distinguishes the cloud BigTable serving
code from any other code the answer is
we have a system called binary
authorization which is quite novel and
actually as of today it's something that
you can start to play with on kubernetes
on cloud and what it does is it lets us
tie those production service identities
to specific pieces of code and processes
by which that code is managed and
deployed so in our particular example we
would say we only want to put the cloud
BigTable service identity on the ACL if
it was built from the particular build
target in our source repository that
corresponds to the cloud BigTable
serving system and we want to know that
all that code that went in there was
reviewed by a second person so one
engineer couldn't make a mistake and
screw the whole thing up we want to make
sure that code was built by our trusted
build system we want to make sure that
it was released in accordance with our
mandated release process binary
authorization lets us do all these
things and in fact we do do them so for
something to get access to that user
data it has to pass all these steps it
has to be code that was purpose-built to
do this one thing it has to been
reviewed it has to been built it has to
have been deployed in a proper fashion
and finally it has to present that
strong cryptographic identity this is
the kind of thing that gives us
confidence in the overall operation of
the system
so I've given you actually a pretty
brief overview of our text sack if
you're interested to learn more and you
want to get more details and information
there's actually a fairly detailed
technical white paper on our site if you
go to cloud google.com slash security
it's called the security infrastructure
white paper so I encourage anyone who's
interested in learning more to take a
look all right so that's the technology
part but as Jo said earlier you can't
run an entire cloud just with technology
you need to have operations you need
people to improve the service to
maintain the service to provide support
and our thinking is that defensive
controls start in the data center that's
literally where the data is so you have
to protect it and the first line of
defense is physical security right we
actually have multiple layers of defense
we actually have armed guards we have
retina scanning we have fingerprint
scanning and I know because I've
actually been to a data center floor and
let me tell you it is very hard to get
on to that floor if you're not supposed
to be there especially past those laser
beams
we have a strict access management
system and what that does is it says
these specific kinds of people and these
specific job roles are allowed unto the
floor at specific times for a specific
reason
right so again it's difficult to get on
to the floor to even be near the
machines or where the data lives unless
you have a very good reason to be there
and we know what you're doing and
finally we retrospectively look at who
in fact was out there why they were
there and we ordered that to make sure
that everything was appropriate did you
have to get past the laser beam to get
on the floor as well I did I did I
started contortionism for about six
months but if you've seen the movie mr.
and mrs. Smith it was a lot like that ok
cool yeah
so so we said that we need people to
administer our cloud right and that
means that those people themselves can
become targets right if I'm an attacker
if I want to gain access
to Google's data how am I gonna do it
well I might go after someone who works
at Google right so it should protect our
employees we use those two techniques I
mentioned before we have phishing
resistant hardware authentication in the
form of security keys which is something
we recommend that everybody use and is
something which on cloud you can
actually mandate that all your employees
use as well and we mandate the use of
managed access devices so you can't just
pick up a random laptop and start
debugging Google cloud software you have
to come from a specific device that's
been provisioned by Google and managed
to be in a good state okay so you're a
person at Google you need to do some
support work or administrative work we
still want to make sure that only the
right people have access to things and
they're only doing things for the right
reason
so here - we have role based access
controls if you don't work on cloud
BigTable in a support role you're not
going to ever have access to cloud
BigTable resources our support tools are
purpose-built so if your work and
support the only way for you to gain
access to say metadata about a BigTable
is to use this support tool and the
support tool will require you to say why
you're doing something so if you can't
produce the specific customer support
ticket as an example that is the thing
that you're following up on taxes that
specific resource you're not going to
get access and finally again we employ
auditing very extensively it's a good
way for us to make sure that people are
using their access appropriately all the
time so let's come back to that question
the Jo raised early on am I secure in
the cloud I mean I can't answer that
question for you but I can say and
hopefully you have a sense now that we
have made an enormous investment in
security we have I think over 900 people
working on security and privacy alone
and the only way that we're able to make
this kind of an investment is because we
operate at such a large scale
it actually makes financial sense for us
to do this
we have so much at stake and we can
amortize that cost over a very large
number of machines now this is something
that customers can do on their own in
part but it's very expensive to do that
so we actually think that for most
customers they're going to end up having
the same or better security as they move
to a public cloud by taking advantage of
these kind of sophisticated features
that we've built so that actually brings
us to pillar number three accountability
it's well and good for me to talk to you
about our technology for me to talk to
you about our operations for us to
publish white papers I think these are
actually all very important things we're
trying to be as open and transparent as
we can about how we run our clouds so
you can have that as a basis for trust
but we think it's really important too
to give you direct accountability what
is Google actually doing why are they
doing it and the reason we think that's
so important is we have to hold
ourselves accountable we understand why
this is so important when you run a
system like Gmail you worry about
accidental exposure of data you worry
about unmonitored access by admins this
is something that we do all the time and
the way we hold ourselves accountable
beyond all those access controls which I
mentioned is we have these robust
internal logs we collect detailed logs
of whenever people at Google do things
we funnel them into a central location
and we apply very sophisticated
techniques to try to detect if anything
was being done inappropriately if we
didn't have those kind of controls we
couldn't feel comfortable running those
kinds of services and feeling like they
were actually secure so it's a fair
question as a customer to say all right
well you want me to trust you to run my
business on Google cloud but I don't
have access to those same internal logs
that you have how am I supposed to feel
comfortable well it's exactly to answer
that question that I'm really excited to
announce access transparency it's a new
product offering on GCP it's something
that you're not going to find on any
other cloud
and the point of it is to give you
meaningful oversight of your cloud
provider we're going to give you near
real-time logs when a person at Google
accesses your content we think this is a
really important step in establishing
trust with you the customer and giving
you a basis on which you can build a
secure business in the cloud I think the
best way to understand the concept
behind access transparency is to look at
an example by far the most common reason
anyone at Google would ever have to
access customer content is for support
it's when we're asked to do so so let's
look at an example this is the kind of
thing that certainly happens a customer
is a user of our Google Cloud Storage
API they tried to read one of the
objects in a bucket and the data looks
corrupted and they're not able to figure
out what was going on so they call
support now that action by the customer
admin will generate a cloud audit log so
when we talk about accountability
there's layers of accountability so as a
customer you want to keep tabs and what
your own admins are doing and cloud
audit logging lets you do that you could
see that someone was trying to read this
particular object so now let's look at
the next level they contacted Google
support and so the support person goes
in they're not able to access the
content of the object because that's
just not allowed by our policy in
general but they are able to access
things like the access control lists
because sometimes maybe the problem is
there or maybe it's with other metadata
and they can figure it out without
having to go deeper but in this case
everything looks fine they had to say
why they did it it was to handle this
particular customer support ticket in 1
2 3 4 5 and it all looks fine and
they're gonna have to escalate to
engineering
now before access transparency this is
what you would get to see as a customer
when that access occurred pretty much a
gray box right that's not very
satisfying right
with access transparency it looks very
different you're going to get a law
in near-real-time so we're talking
minutes not days of what specific thing
was accessed and you could see here it's
the particular object that was accessed
and at the end you could see it was just
the ACL not the content of the object
itself you get to see what type of
action was performed and you get to see
the reason for that access right because
the point of this is to say yes I can
account for each thing that occurred
this makes sense to me I understand why
it happened
so let's go to the next level right we
couldn't resolve the problem with
support we had to get engineering
involved and engineering has access to
lower level debugging tools than support
typically does right so they can
actually go into the underlying systems
where the things live they can use the
internal api's to try to pull more data
to figure out what's what's going on
alright so in this case again the
engineer has to say a justification so
they're doing it for this reason this
particular ticket number and they're
able to get the data and say okay I see
what happened the data had a different
encoding than the one that you thought
and that's why the data appeared to be
corrupted we're able to recover and so
everything's good
notify the customer great importantly
you're gonna get another log when this
happens and this time you can actually
see that the content of the object was
accessed right that's the level of
granularity and transparency we think is
really important for us to offer I'd
like to spend just one more minute
talking about what I like to call deep
transparency versus shallow transparency
so I mentioned that support accounts for
the vast majority of accesses right that
support requested by the customer is I
don't know the exact figures but it's
like 8090 percent something like that
and so that seems like oh it's not that
hard we have a purpose-built support
tool
let's go instrument the tool will get
some logs and we'll send them over to
the customer no big deal
right and that is definitely way better
than nothing right it turns out actually
not to be that easy
in the end but you could do it we
decided to go beyond that we wanted to
say okay even though we could give you
80% of the logs for 10% of the effort
that doesn't really fulfill the point of
this feature the point of this feature
is to tell you as much as possible but
every time that someone at Google access
your content and so we wanted to get
those deeper access points those
internal api's those low-level
general-purpose storage systems to be
part of this solution too now it turns
out there's way more code there are a
lot more systems there than in our
support system right it's an order of
magnitude more stuff maybe even more and
it only gives us 10% 5% of the logs
something like that but it felt like the
right thing to do and that's the kind of
thing that we're hoping to do going
forward and bring it to all GCP for you
okay with that I'm gonna hand it back
over to Joe to show you a demo of the
system in action thanks Mitch okay so
let's take a look at how access
transparency would actually work in real
life
so let's slow this down a little bit so
it's easier to it's easier for everyone
here to see I'm gonna slow it down to
half speed and so I'm going to go ahead
and I'm going to open up a bucket and
I'm gonna try an axe as a file and I got
this error permission denied on cloud
KMS key so it's not good I'm gonna go
and contact support and see if they can
help me out so this is not what exactly
what the support person sees but it's
roundabout exactly how the experience
works support person inserts this
justification
it says case number 202 one two three
now try and remember that case number
because it's going to come back later
not I'm not testing you so they insert
that justification and it's checked it
says okay this person has that ticket
open I'm going to give them access and
they actually end up saying to you this
there was this issue and you fix it
and the the date is showing up fine so
that's great so you're gonna say okay I
fixed my issue let me go to the to the
login panel and see what logs showed up
and now you can see that in the login
panel there's access transparency logs
available because you contacted support
so we can go ahead and bring those logs
up and I'm going to expand this panel
because I want to see a little bit more
detail about what's inside these logs
I'm gonna pick this log here I go and
take a closer look and there it is I've
got information about exactly what
happened and most importantly here I've
got the reason so there's that case
number again two oh two one two three so
the full sort of audit pathway showing
me everything best of all it works with
all my features in stock driver logging
so I can set up metrics I can set up
alerting I can get it to send me an
email and we have another session on
this tomorrow morning SEC to 11 at 9:00
a.m. if you want to learn more about how
exactly this can be accomplished but for
now the only important thing to know is
it works just like any other log on
stack Java so that was a little bit hard
to see so maybe let's let's jump out of
this and let's let's take a look at
let's maybe you maximize that let's take
a look at this log in a little bit more
detail so I want to zoom into the top
part of our access transparency log and
just talk through the information that's
contained inside it so the first line
there is type and you can clearly see
that it says transparency log why is
that useful if you want to go ahead and
set up alerts or monitoring on these
particular types of logs if we want to
go and fire off an email to an auditor
that says please check exactly what
happened every time we see one of these
things we can use this field to match so
we can see that it's a transparency log
the second section gives a bit more
information about the Google employee
who made the access so you can clearly
see here that we've got the principal
office country that the person was
is typically located in we also have the
principal physical location country so
that is a special field that is going to
tell you exactly where the person making
the access was at the time that the
access was made we've got some special
technology that allows us to be able to
make that determination and then it also
tells us the employing entity of the
Google so it tells us here that that
Google employee works for the Google LLC
that's our American entity and this
might be useful for you if you have
specific government sort of governance
risk and compliance needs for this
particular information it's the second
part of the log this gives a bit more
information about exactly what was
accessed so here you can see cloud
storage there was a read executed on it
and the resource name was this
particular bucket slash ACL which means
access control list so I can identify
that the person in question didn't look
at the content they were looking at the
access control list of this object and
finally reason so I can see here that
the reason is given its a clearly
specified what the case number is and I
can go ahead and pull that case number
up and perform an audit against it to
see if it's what I expected
if I open up a ticket that said please
you know investigate why I can't access
my cloud storage and then you know I had
a bunch of all these logs going on and
on and on and on for days I might be
like why did that happen so that gives
you that audit trail that is able to
connect everything together you'll
notice that there's also another field
called type so the type specifies that
it is a customer initiated support
access and as mesh mention the absolute
vast majority of all the accesses our
customer initiated there are a few cases
in which they may not be in our
documentation which you can find online
we talked a little bit more in detail
about exactly why we might otherwise
access your data so I spoke about
customer initiated support you contact
us you say hey I need some help with
something that's the most common one
there's also Google initiated service
now this is by far second most common
one and it's where there's
or an outage or some issue where we
detect that there's a problem and we
need to go and fix it
then there's third-party data requests
and that's to do with sort of things
like court-ordered accesses or legal
accesses and finally there's Google
initiated review and that's to do with
things like abuse or security reviews
and I know that you may have custom
terms that allayed opt out of that be of
some of those particular review cases
I'm not going to go into detail and read
all these I'd encourage you to get to
our documentation to learn more but I
just wanted to highlight that if one of
these four reasons isn't present then
the data will never be accessed
so access transparency what are the key
features what does it cover think about
it as covering all the data you give us
so unless it's a public resource
identifier like a GCS bucket name we
will give you an access transparency log
when it gets accessed and that's
important because even something as
small as the name of a VM or a label
that you've attached to a VM we're going
to treat that like it's your customer
data and we're going to give you a log
of it when whenever it's accessed and we
did that because we didn't want to make
value judgments about what it is that
you find to be important or not
important we just want to give you as
much transparency as we can over your
content and what's happening to it on
the cloud timeliness you're going to get
these logs in near-real-time
as image said it's minutes not days
availability you can get it through
stackdriver logging as we saw and you
can also get it through our cloud
logging api's and through a new offering
from sa P called data custodian these
logs have audit grade protections too
similar to your audit logs you can't
delete them unless you delete the
project or the organization that gives
you that extra protection that a bad
actor hasn't gone and removed records of
what's happened and retention we hold
them for free for 13 months now some
additional important details are that
access transparency logs cover human
accesses through support and debugging
pathways so in these cases you'll get
your real-time logs accesses that are
made pursue
to legal investigations will typically
surface in near-real-time
however there may be cases where we're
prohibited from by law from surfacing
those and they won't show up then this
system access and these are things like
in indexing jobs but they could be other
jobs that run in our system as a man
explained before we have this
comprehensive system of binary
authorization that verifies that the
code that's touching this data in
BigTable comes from the BigTable service
and because of those controls we don't
generate access transparency logs in
those cases because we have binary
authorization in place and then finally
accesses to very low level storage
systems these are extremely rare haven't
seen one yet but these are not real-time
at present there's a human in the loop
at the moment we will have real time
availability though in q4
so you may be asking at this point
what's new we've already detailed the
fact that we don't access your data for
reasons other than necessary to provide
you your service in our Terms of Service
and what access transparency just does
is give you another layer of visibility
over that commitment and it's part of a
long list of transparency commitments
we've been making at Google over many
years
these include our tech white papers that
you can go ahead and read to learn about
how a platform works our compliance
certifications we have a transparency
report we've been publishing for over a
decade we were the first to start doing
this and that details everything about
government and legal actions logs of
your own admins on your service through
cloud audit logging and now finally logs
of Google admins through access
transparency access transparency will be
in general availability coming very soon
it will be available for compute engine
persistent disk cloud storage App Engine
cloud I am and kms it's available to
Platinum and Gold customers only
order your equivalents in role-based
support and you can enable it today on
the GCP website just go to google.com
and search access transparency and it
should come up first I hope so
thanks very much to find out more you
can head to our website and I'm now
going to invite Liz Vasquez the
head of cloud security at HSBC on stage
to talk a couple of questions about how
HSBC is using Access transparency Thanks
sorry yeah sure okay thanks for joining
us this so there's we heard a little bit
yesterday in the keynote about how HSBC
is moving a lot of your big data stuff
and many other applications onto Google
cloud platform but as a big part of that
you know transparency was important in
making that move so can you talk to us
about why access transparency was so
important for you right to that point so
my job is cloud security so as my
company is moving our data to Google I
am the one that needs to look at what
are all the controls we have in place so
we're looking at all the type of attack
vectors attack paths that we have Google
is providing us tons of access controls
and network layers access controls from
our admins as you said all the cloud
audit logging we had but there was a
space where that's where the trust comes
in and the question kept coming up where
well what if our access our data is
accessed by someone that's not within
our control so HSBC can control or is
looking at all the actions of our
employees right we are we are limiting
the roles we're limiting what people can
and cannot do what buckets they can
access so this was the the last area of
trust for us is well what if you know
our buckets which have this highly
private and restricted data are accessed
by Google and then the question comes up
well don't you trust them right this is
Google after all and and yes we do trust
them but that's where we always say
insecurity is trust but verify right so
access transparency is really helping us
to be able to tell the auditors listen
this is why we're going to the cloud
these are all the steps we are doing and
even when we're calling Google for
support even when it's them legitimately
touching our buckets for something that
we've requested
we have a way of verifying that so we
are alerted when we get access
transparency log access so that we can
say yep we see that Google access to our
bucket which bucket it was and which
action was taken so I want to know that
it was a read action I want to know
which bucket they actually read and I
want to know that it was based on on a
support ticket from us so that's really
important for us great and I think
you've already sort of started touching
on a little bit of this but I just
wanted to know a bit more about how
you've got that sort of alerting system
set up on your side so are you saying
it's alerts that are coming now from
from the boss no because thank God you
guys thought about that and already set
it up with stackdriver logging so we
have stock driver logging that's fitting
into our seam so and I just noticed
yesterday that because we've just
started playing with security command
center that you're also bubbling that up
there so we we also have more plans of
furthering and use the security command
center both within several of our teams
obviously the seam has use cases where
we can send that to our sock but yeah
they're there for me it's just important
it's like we have all the options so we
can direct it to our seam hub use cases
there or if someone actually just wants
to use security command center which
which we're starting to figure out which
which people we want to give access to
that as well just so that everybody has
visibility that it's also showing there
which is great awesome
[Music]